I still think awards are stupid right
but they'd be less stupid if they went
to the right
people Ron it's actually not that
serious I just need you to stay calm
okay yeah I'm I'm just going to stay
angry I find that relaxes me and I'll
have the number eight that's a party
platter serves 12 people I know what I'm
about son and one number eight all right
party time I would suggest sticking
around and watching him eat it cuz it
only takes 4 minutes and it's pretty
amazing these will not be
necessary I got a second box of donuts
if
anybody what the is this this Mr
director is your new desk okay excuse me
there's a sign at ramit Park that says
do not drink the sprinkler water so I
made sun tea with it and now I have an
infection
sir sir are are are are you listening to
me sir sir I'm talking to you sir sir
are you aware that there is waste in
your water system I would prefer that
she asked me for my permission so I can
say no I like saying
no it lowers their
enthusiasm on my deathbed my final wish
is to have my Ex-Wives rush to my side
so I can use my dying breath to tell
them both to go to hell one last time
would I get married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of
living I got to tell you Ron you were
absolutely and totally right I know stop
talking and get out
yep all told we were in there about 6
hours and no I was not meditating I just
stood there quietly breathing there were
no thoughts in my head whatsoever my
mind was blank I don't know what the
hell these other crackpots are doing
well I've never been one for meeting new
people or doing new things or eating new
types of food or traveling outside of
Southern Indiana I've had the same
haircut since 1978 and have driven the
same car since 1991 I've used the same
wooden comb for three
decades I have one bowl Nutri hams
energy bars are just absolutely loaded
with fruct toast corn syrup and fatty
oils and any way you slice it they're
just extremely unhealthy for you Leslie
needs to butt out the whole point of
this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 lb and die of
a heart attack at 43 you can you are
free to do so to me that's beautiful the
less I know about other people's Affairs
the happier I am I'm not interested in
caring about people I once worked with a
guy for 3 years and never learned his
name name best friend I ever
had we still never talk sometimes
normally if given a choice between doing
something and nothing I'd choose to do
nothing but I will do something if it
helps someone else do nothing I'd work
all night if it meant nothing got done
Larry salami the human resources
department requires that I be available
once a month to discuss workplace
disputes with my employees the rules do
not specify whether or not I'm allowed
to Listen to Willie Nelson on my
headphones and Kyle parked his car in my
spotting again now that is the fourth
time this month hello sorry everybody
makes mes he at me he thinks
he's go for you today I just want to
choke him until he passes out night Ron
night
Ron
ladies
[Applause]
thank you all for being here let's get
started wow great attitude
Ron sorry I was talking to these ribs
okay so the Valentine's Day dance is hey
Ann if you get this I don't know if you
should come up here he's not worth it
okay just call me let me know where you
are and if you
have Ron what in the devil's name is
this portella mushrooms where's the
Steak oh there's no mistake that's a
healthier option it's organically
grown H you okay whoa whoa wao okay can
you get us a cold compress or
something just give me the IP address of
the dude that gave me that cracked out
Yelp review okay here we go the IP
address says it came from someone inside
City Hall in this building oh hell no
well who cares really it's just some
dumb internet person ignore it ignore it
I'm about to come down on this dude like
Thor's hammer m
I'm about to go M on his
ass speaking of bad reviews computers
are mostly pointless but that Yelp thing
gave me a great idea on how to criticize
people in
places I am composing strongly worded
letters about things I disapprove of and
I am using the internet to get addresses
where I can send them so far I've
written to a vegetable farm several
European ambassadors a manufacturer of
male cologne and a non-fat Frozen Yogurt
Bar dear frozen yogurt you are the
celery of desserts be ice cream or be
nothing zero
Stars third time
today that's a good Sho
shine
what the man I I don't know what
happened frankly an was getting a little
chummy when people get too chummy with
me I like to call them by the wrong name
to let them know I don't really care
about them that's a genius move thank
you you're welcome
Lester the key to burning an ex-wife
Effigy is to dip it in paraffin wax and
then Toss The Flaming bottle of
isopropyl alcohol from a safe distance
do not stand too close when you light an
ex-wife
Effigy hey what about you Mr uh a man's
word is sacred well it is but you're an
ass Hey Ron you're not going to
slaughter that pig here are you not to
worry I have a
permit this just says I can do what I
want I am the director of the parks
department and this is a park it's not a
Parks thing it's against like three laws
and a dozen Health
codes just so you know it's not your
typical bar they specialize in molecular
Mixology it's kind of like a an
experimental new way to consume alcohol
son there's no wrong way to consume
alcohol
here's your Bud Light I ordered a beer
that is a beer and here's your Nimbus
Martini may I go ahead and chisel your
aromasphere
please this is the wrong way to consume
alcohol wa that's a pretty stiff Cloud
where did the scotch right here hold out
your hands
please what's happening oh this is a
sort of play on Scotch it's the whis
infused lotion can I ask if this entire
establishment is a practical joke of
some kind Ron Swanson it is my pleasure
to inform you that you are a finalist
for the job of assistant city manager
Chris I feel I should remind you that I
do not believe that the position or the
entire government should exist that said
you'd be a fool not to pick me I will
walk deeper into the belly of the Beast
if it means I'm able to further limit
Reckless government spending I mean I
have so many ideas some are simple like
take down traffic lights and eliminate
the post office the bigger ones will be
tougher like bring all of this crumbling
to the
ground this is a mistake why would you
call it that on your menu I don't know
what to tell you
man just give me all the bacon and eggs
you have wait wait I worry what you just
heard was give me a lot of bacon and
eggs what I said was give me all the
bacon and eggs you
have do you
understand every year I give Leslie the
same present I give everyone a crisp $20
bill and every year she gets me
something thoughtful and personal it
makes me
Furious this year she outdid
herself
she had it installed over the
weekend it's
so so
beautiful